habituellement les contrôles de
pesticides se font ici en sortie d'usiné
mais pour cette étude les scandales
récents ont poussé les agences
régionales de santé effectué les
contrôles à la sortie du robinet 62
points de prélèvements au total répartis
sur l'ensemble du territoire et 435
pesticides recherché dans le chlordécone
une étude menée par un laboratoire
indépendant
entre juin et décembre 2019 selon la rs
sur les 62 échantillons prélevés 57 ne
présenterait aucune molécules
phytosanitaires
en revanche cinq révèle la présence de
chlordécone
c'est le cas dans les bourgs de grand
rivière du françois des anses d'arlet de
basse pointe un autre échantillon révèle
la présence de menus rond un herbicide
au quartier st james à saint pierre la
station du vivent et qui une station
importante puisqu'elle produit 15 % de
l'eau utilisée en martinique a réussi à
arrêter 97 % environ de la chlordécone
qui vient de la rivière capot qui est
extrêmement contaminés mais c'est une
ressource dont on ne peut pas se passer
et donc c'est traces de chlordécone qui
sont constatées de façon intermittente à
la sortie de la station du vivent et se
retrouve forcément dans le réseau de
distribution et au robinet une présence
de chlordécone inférieure donc aux
normes européennes
rassurant peut-être mais encore
insuffisant pour certaines associations
je retrouve un corps dans les lmr or
nous au lit en âge pour des policiers
matinik si nous ne voulons que le zéro
clan des codes zéro pesticide 10.5 est
ce que l'on fait de cela au vu de ces
résultats
est-ce qu'on revoie les systèmes de
filtration et puis dans un même temps
comme il s'agit aussi de faire du zéro
pesticide 0 produits toxiques
est ce que les systèmes de floculation
sont revus par exemple est-ce pour
l'aluminium
qu'est ce qui les fait pour les métaux
lourds donc il ya pas mal de questions
que nous nous posons enfin un objectif
zéro chlordécone vers lequel la rsa
affirment aussi vouloir aller d'autant
plus qu'il demeure une préoccupation
importante de la population martinique